hey this is super interesting because
it's a sort of perfect blend of
political propaganda but also of Donald
Trump's fragile psychological state as
we all know Donald Trump was woefully
late to the coronavirus preparedness
game he was behind on taking it
seriously he was behind on procuring
supplies he was behind on shutting
things down he's just been behind we had
our first case on January 20th South
Korea had their first case on January
19th essentially the same day and yet
South Korea immediately developed a test
isolated people did masse testing
quarantine people did contact tracing
they still don't have 200 deaths from
the virus meanwhile we had over 900
deaths just yesterday part of it is
because Donald Trump has failed us but
here's the psychological part Donald
Trump always wants to blame someone else
and in fact he's been asked a number of
times do you take responsibility for
this or that no I don't take
responsibility he has told us but in
order to blame someone else for the
coronavirus response
he's implicitly admitting that the
response was slow or inadequate so
yesterday during the White House
coronavirus press briefing a reporter
asked Donald Trump a brilliant question
from a psychological perspective and
it's brilliant because it was it really
baited Trump into having to make a
decision on the spot the reporter asked
did impeachment back in January distract
you from coronavirus now I'm gonna play
Trump's answer for you but what happens
is amazing again from from the point of
view of analyzing Trump's psyche Trump
gets this look on his face where it's
almost like a light bulb goes off where
he says hey wait a second I could blame
Democrats for this I could say yeah
that's right the phony impeachment hoax
did distract me from coronavirus it's
the Dems fault except if Trump does that
he's implicitly admitting he was
distracted he's he's admitting by
default that the response was not what
it could have been he can blame
Democrats he's been given a
get-out-of-jail-free card here but to do
that he has to admit that he didn't have
the best response and ultimately Trump
does admit that he was distracted by
impeachment now whether it's true or not
we don't we don't really know kind of
doubt it but Trump is calculating in
real-time hey wait a second maybe I can
say okay fine maybe the response wasn't
good but it was because of Democrats
check it out Mitch McConnell yeah he
said that impeachment diverted the
attention of the government do you think
that in any way this was happening and
building at the same time did it divert
your attention or your team's attention
or attention well I don't like to think
I did I think I handle it very well but
I guess it probably did I mean I got
impeached I think you know I certainly
devoted a little time to thinking about
it right so but think of it it was a
hoax it was a total hoax and when you
think that I got impeached only because
they had a majority in the house they
didn't get one then you get one
Republican vote 196 to nothing not one
Republican step I don't think it's ever
happened the Republicans stuck together
and they stuck together in the Senate 52
to 1/2 this just brilliantly twists
Trump into a sort of pretzel and later
he says well even though I was
distracted I don't really know that I
could have done anything differently
he's saying yeah well sort of I was
distracted I was impeached and it was a
hoax and Democrats are bad and it's
Democrats that affected my response but
still my response was as good as it
could have been and I couldn't have done
anything more quickly
Trump's actual answer is worthless here
as a factual inquiry but it is gold as a
window into Trump's psyche which is the
light bulb goes off and he gets this
idea hey wait a second I can blame
Democrats for this and Trump of course
wants to do that but he still has to
argue that despite being distracted by
impeachment he wasn't distracted enough
to do anything wrong on coronavirus
response it's incredible and it is quite
a window into Donald Trump's desperation
to figure out how can he untwist himself
from this intractable situation where
he was slow the response was a joke his
communications have been
disproportionately propaganda every once
in a while with some kind of action item
sprinkled in there and an excellent job
by the reporter whose name escapes me
and I apologize I really should be
naming him because he did a really good
job they're very very interesting we
have a very full show for you today I
want to remind you on April 9th that's
next Thursday okay we are doing a 1-day
membership bomb I'm gonna share
something with you that is not good news
it's April 1st so now we have our March
numbers 389 people canceled memberships
in March okay that's by far the worst
cancellation month we've ever had and
it's because of the virus people are
having to tighten the belt people are
canceling what is certainly
discretionary spending and I get that
that's what we are as an independent
media show but we've got to do something
because we want to you know we've lost a
couple of advertisers the membership
thing is tough so we want to do
something to try to sort of fight back
and and and really try to even this out
so on April 9th 2 p.m. Eastern 11:00
a.m. Pacific we're gonna send out an
email to everybody on our newsletter
mailing list with the biggest discount
code of the year we want to try to have
this one-day membership bomb to try to
win back some of the support that we we
knew it would eventually happen and it
did start to happen in those last couple
weeks of March so please sign up for our
newsletter at david pakman.com you just
put in your email address you don't have
to email me you do it on my website
david pakman.com get on the newsletter a
Thursday April 9th
you'll get that email from me and
hopefully we can recover some of that
lost ground real quick I want to tell
you about our sponsor magic spoon who
have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals that we know we
shouldn't eat anymore and turn them into
something you can actually feel good
about eating as an adult there's four
flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry they taste great they're
crunchy they're sweet like you would
expect this type of cereal to be but
it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one Bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain free soy
free once our team tried magic spoon for
the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit with David Pakman
show staffers and magic spoon knows how
delicious their cereal is because if you
don't like it they'll refund all of your
money no questions asked and you'll get
free shipping when you go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman and use the code
Pakman that's PA que ma N